Dot Com
Mr Holocaust is a political prisoner.
He is in prison as a result of it.
Political conflict.
Why I punted,
that's 30 seconds of my time on the 1993
events.
It's because they relevant to this day.
That is a political conflict about the
only choice available for posts.
Their societies.
Either they are going to be strong,
quite authoritarian states,
societies that have been killed.
You destroyed about the Soviet system
with no separate institutions,
checks and balances or they will be
privatized.
They will be taken over.
Then we'll become oligarchs systems.
This is what we saw in Russia in the
late 1990s.
Mr Berry's Husky was an actor,
uh,
in that process and to that extent we're
privileged to have him with us today.
Don't be naive.
This is the system which had a costco
wants to bring back.
Was there some other process at work
that created these immensely wealthy and
not just wealthy but incredibly powerful
families?
No.
As I understand it,
Mr. Pin sharp got a lot of his money
because he was the beneficiary of state
sells off of,
of assets.
When Leo needs to put Shamar was
precedent and there is something
remarkable.
There is something to me utterly
remarkable about his wife,
Iliana friendship,
describing herself as a philanthropist
because she gives some money to aids
when so much money has been got by that
family from the Ukraine.
It is a little bit like somebody
stealing your wallet and everything in
it and then giving you $10 back and
saying,
I'm a philanthropist.
For
sure.
I would like to stress the most
transparent and the most powerful
Russian company today he caught and
other who presented this company in Jay.
And it's very important to understand
that the west,
except the rules for that Kowski because
the world of Ucas company at the best
celebrities of their Western Wall quit
quick set.
He's conception call except the
company's transparent and put your
destroyed it completely.